un último adiós para beber lópez vázquez
amigos y familiares velaron su cuerpo el
viernes luego de la trágica muerte del
periodista se trata del más reciente en
una serie de crímenes contra reporteros
en este 2022 yo creo que no merecía el
compañero
hacerle ese llamado atención si es que
ellos quisieran hacer eso con el hecho
que hicieron de cinco impactos de bala
la verdad es es lamentable este hecho se
ve que esta gente era un odio contra el
compañero cuando el compañero solamente
hacía la labor de informar el jueves el
director del portal noticias web recibió
cinco impactos de bala cuando estaba en
su oficina ubicada en la ciudad de
salina cruz las autoridades detuvieron a
dos de los presuntos agresores
el presidente mexicano lamentó la muerte
del comunicador y prometió que no habrá
impunidad puede ser
que esté
se cometan estos lamentables crímenes
e impunidad pero ante las continuas
represalias de los cárteles de droga que
operan en varios estados y las elevadas
tasas de corrupción ser periodista en
méxico significa en muchas ocasiones
arriesgar la vida según la ong artículo
19 en defensa de la libertad de
expresión
149 periodistas han sido asesinados en
méxico desde el año 2000 en posible
relación con su labor méxico sigue
siendo uno de los países más peligrosos
para el periodismo y nos ven desde
afuera como eso como un país sin capaz
como una autoridad incapaz de contener
estos crímenes una indagación está en
curso en el caso de la muerte de heber
lópez vázquez sin embargo varias voces
entre ongs y gobiernos piden que se
realice una investigación transparente
en diciembre el mismo subsecretario de
derechos humanos población inmigración
de la secretaría de gobernación de
méxico alejandro encinas admitió que la
impunidad en los homicidios de
reporteros y activistas supera el 90 por
ciento